young person you'll find in your life
that sometimes your great ambitions will
be momentarily stymied forted
marginalized by those who were perhaps
luckier come from money where more doors
opened where college was a given it was
not a student loan it was something that
dad paid for to wear an ease and
confidence in life was almost a
birthright where for you it was a very
hard climb okay that happens all the
time
some of the greatest Americans some of
the greatest thinkers artists architects
politicians and other movers shakers and
creators all over the world have come
from very meager beginnings like my
favorite American Abraham Lincoln and so
just because you come from nothing you
must not let that be something that
holds you back and you will encounter
people who never have to pay in full
they get to wreck the room and never
have to clean it they can get all the
way through high school and never
understand where a dollar comes from
because they just get it given to them I
went to school with guys like that
you've had presidents like that you've
had friends like that and you've you've
suffered your humility has been tried
your patience has been tried your
resolve and your ambition has been tried
you cannot let these people make you
feel that you have in any way been
dwarfed or outclassed
you must really go for your own and
realize how short life is you got what
you got so you got to make the most of
it
you really can't spend a whole lot of
time worrying about his you really have
to go for your own if you have an idea
of what you want to do in your future
you must go at it with almost monastic
obsession
be it music the ballet or just a basic
degree you have to go at it single
mindedly and let nothing get in your way
and that's why you're young that's why
you can survive on no sleep top ramen
noodles and dental floss and still look
good and take advantage of that great
energy you have the fact that you can do
an all-nighter all the people you admire
from Muhammad Ali to any politician they
work and work and work
got like Bill Clinton not everyone's
favorite Rhodes Scholar he's smart for a
reason a got a great and great mind but
he sat and he shoved a whole bunch of
information in there
and he learned how to connect the dots
and so can you your president right now
is a man who got where he is through
very hard work and scholarships mainly
hard work an application and discipline
if these people can do it why not you it
is very very easy though to feel smaller
to feel less then when you see see
people with an advantage walk where you
struggle who have ease of motion where
you are constricted it can be a real
shot to your morale like it can be
flummoxing to a degree where you're
almost paralytic you got to keep picking
yourself up and reaching for it and
that's the long and short of it because
if you don't it won't get done
you